stable diffusion has been released to
the public and the world is creative as
never before it's an explosion of
creativity collaboration and open
Improvement but not everyone is happy
today we'll look at how stable diffusion
Works how it impacts the world and what
people say about it welcome to a special
edition of ml news
[Music]
you may remember imatma stock who I had
as an interview guest here on the
channel the founder of stability AI has
announced on August 22nd the public open
source release of stable diffusion
stable diffusion is a text to image
model you give it a piece of text and it
makes an image and the images it creates
are stunning this image right here these
images are created by stable diffusion
this is not Photoshop this doesn't just
adjust a little bit in existing image it
creates images from Pure text so the
cool thing about stable diffusion is
that while similar models have been just
available behind an API like open ai's
Dali this is completely in the open you
can just download the model and do
whatever you want with it a small point
there is actually a license on it but
it's very permissive so almost whatever
you want specifically you can change it
you can update it you can monetize it
and all of that stuff it's been trained
on a subset of the lion 5B data set
that's been been filtered for
specifically aesthetically pleasing
images and that is a big part of why the
results are so amazing and the craziest
thing about all of this is this model
does not need a data center to run it
can actually run on a single GPU look
this thing right here is enough to run
the model give you the most beautiful
images this enables so many people to
take part and by the way if you want the
3090 I'm giving away one of them hey
tionic from the future quick addendum
it's actually a 3090 TI not just the
3090 so even better alright back to me
in the past not only one I'm giving away
one that's signed by Jensen Huang the
CEO of Nvidia all you've got to do to
take part is stay until the end of the
video I'll tell you exactly how you can
get it so here is how something like
this would work you go to the hugging
face demo or to the stable diffusion
dream studio and you enter a prompt a
bird with a funny hat now look at that
birds with funny hats and you know what
happens when you release a model to the
open when you release software for
anyone to just use and adapt great
things people almost immediately started
improving this thing look at that all of
a sudden someone figures out how to only
use half as much memory well now the
model runs on even more devices look at
that someone built an on an X exporter
well now I can throw it on sagemaker
throw it into a tritone server people
are writing tutorials how to run the
model locally and in a collab oh look at
that it's a little tool to make a
collage picture one picture two picture
three and the overlapping regions will
just match look at that in painting
amazing what it's an anime series about
Oprah and Kyoto and look people are
figuring out how to run it on an M1 Max
GPU no wait people are figuring out how
to run it on an M2 in less than 30
seconds look at this stuff this is
created on a laptop incredible I guess
we're doing videos now look here's a
bunch of Bubbles and formulas alright
biomorphic video this is certainly
trippy Memento Mori a video consistency
different styles looks amazing oh look
there's a hugging face space called
diffuse the rest what do you do you draw
something look at that all right house
house
diffuse the rest
look at that house nice house house
house
and the biomorphic thing is still going
and this enables so much look here
children's drawing cool art children's
drawing cool art children's drawing cool
art look at that squirrel squirrel
dragon dragon but you see what's
happening here people are taking this
and they're making all kinds of stuff
they're improving it in various ways and
they are infinitely creative this is an
explosion of creativity all of a sudden
you don't need the skills of a painter
anymore you don't need Photoshop skills
or anything like that look at that it's
lexicon it's a search engine where you
can search through previously generated
images along with their prompts look at
this stuff this is so cool and it's all
accessible it's all available and people
are becoming so good at prompting these
models look at this one this essentially
has a few of the prompt tricks like
stunning gorgeous much detail much WoW
but the actual content of the picture is
just a bunch of emojis a burger bunch of
houses a tiger a fountain Harry Styles
as a manga cover and this is just the
beginning people are making web uis for
the model you remember how Dali proudly
presented the fact that you could make
variation of images using their API you
can do that too it's a simple radio app
away look at that input image submit get
your variations absolutely crazy you
remember clip guided diffusion well how
about clip guided stable diffusion bear
holding a lollipop over the rooftop of
Hong Kong looking at a UFO oh look
hugging face has a library called
diffusers all look stable diffusion is
now in diffusers dad why is my sister's
name Rose because your mother loves
roses thanks Dad no problem stable
diffusion evolution of the typical
American living room from 1950 to 2040.
according to stable diffusion look at
that 50s 60s
70s tell me this is not crazy look
stable diffusion is now in mid-journey
and the quality is so good oh what
people are building Photoshop plugins
look at that in paint and paint paint
around well this seems pretty cool too
don't know what it is but pretty nice
this is what happens when you give
people the opportunity and the tools to
build when you give them access when you
give them the freedom to make what they
want they make absolutely great things
this thing here it's an alternative web
UI well why only rely on one company
making a web UI why not give users the
option then choose the best these models
are so good and versatile look at this
stuff it's amazing I don't know what
this is but nice so people are
experimenting with this stuff figuring
out what's going on right here which
parameters do what lots of Investigation
into the model because it's just
accessible there's entire notebooks just
trying to figure out what the individual
parts of the model do how you change
stuff what happens when you change stuff
not only do people build great things
around the model people also understand
the model much better and therefore are
able to push it to improve it in a much
greater speed this one's called visual
grounding guided in painting So up here
you have an astronaut you say the part
that you want to replace helmet what do
you want to replace it with flower and I
mean it's not exactly only the helmet
but you can see where this is going
these are just the first iterations of
an entire age that we are about to begin
note how crazy this is just a
combination of two or three of these
models made it such that I don't even
have to click anywhere in the image I
can just interact with these things via
text we are just natural language how
many people does this make art and
design and in general creative Endeavors
accessible too oh wow it's Jeff vlon
Zucker Gates look at all the variations
of things that are in there this is
crazy now as I said we're only at the
start and people are improving this day
by day by day one Improvement that I
would specifically like to highlight is
called textual inversion textual
inversion is a technique where you take
a bunch of images like a very few New
Image is 5 images 10 images of a thing
and you tell you teach the model about
that thing and once you've done that the
model kind of knows the concept of that
thing and can then make new generations
according to the theme so here's what I
mean for example here you give it a
bunch of images of a yoga pose and you
teach the model that this is kind of a
New Concept you can give it a name in
this case they call it s star because if
you could use any name in the world
obviously you would choose s Star as a
name in any case now you can give this s
star to the model along with a prompt
and the model will create images
according to that concept so this is a
great way to teach this model new things
that it didn't know about you can't do
it with every and anything but you can
sort of teach it a concept and look
textual inversion is already in hugging
face diffusers and look there is already
a library of pre-made things that people
have taught the stable diffusion model
so all of these things are Concepts that
people have previously ran textual
inversion on and therefore you can
simply take these Concepts and generate
images according to these Concepts Super
Mario World Map yeah let's use that sir
land snw map
not exactly but this is my very first
try so we'll get there now about a week
after the release of stable diffusion
opening I released a blog post that
they're now introducing out painting to
their Dali API Dolly being the model
that they've trained they have behind
their API they let you interact with it
if you are on the beta users list so now
you can take a picture and you can sort
of out paint from it generate
surroundings of that picture according
to Dali I guess what instead of waiting
for open AI to build this into their API
with stable diffusion someone can just
go and make it someone can just take the
model and build a little UI that does
out painting look at that give it a
prompt click there's a window there's
girl now I can't say whether this is in
response to stable diffusion or just by
accident but open AI also update their
pricing recently to make it
significantly cheaper to use their text
apis now dully the image generator is
still in beta but also there they now
have a commercial model so for 115
Generations you're paying 15 but
therefore you're allowed to
commercialize the images that you get
out of Dolly now as you can see right
here in the official UI of stable
diffusion the one from stability AI an
image cost One Credit One credit is one
cent that's over 10 times cheaper than
Dolly and keep in mind you can just
download the model and run it yourself
although I'm pretty sure like the
electricity is gonna cost more than a
cent per image and stable diffusion
images that you make obviously you're
able to commercialize those from the day
it was publicly released but the battle
between the API model of open Ai and the
open model of stability yeah it doesn't
end there open AI has recently announced
they are now reducing bias and improving
safety in Dali 2. they released a blog
post where they say they're implementing
a new technique so that the LI generate
images of people that more accurately
reflect the diversity of the world's
population they simply say a new
technique and they give an example when
they search for a photo of a CEO or
rather generate a photo of a CEO you see
it's just men and with their new
technique it is a rainbow of people of
different ethnicities and genders and so
on now again they don't say what the new
technique is but people were wondering
because it's not that easy to mitigate
this kind of stuff now people found that
there are some rather interesting side
effects of this for example if they
generate a professional DSLR color
photograph of British soldiers during
the American Revolution it seems to be
let's say historically rather inaccurate
and now it shows again how creative
people are so in order to figure out
what's running since we can't expect the
code people came up with the idea maybe
they're just kind of modifying your
prompt so people entered as a pro prompt
the sentence a person holding a sign
that says but that's the prompt and what
comes out this picture gets out of that
other people have reproduced this The
Prompt here says pixel art of a person
holding a text sign that says and the
picture is that so it turns out that the
technique that open AI is advertising is
they simply have like a predefined list
of things and they append these things
to your prompt thereby potentially
completely destroying your prompt but
neither would they say what the
technique is nor do they let you opt out
of the technique like in the name of
safety they don't trust you they can't
just say you know we actually found that
this pretty simple thing mitigates a lot
of the bias if you just append these
kind of words to The Prompt then it
actually works pretty well you'll get a
pretty diverse result if you want to do
so take it under consideration use it in
our API we even made like a button for
you to automatically append these words
this would have been so much better than
them just saying we have a new technique
and no we're not gonna let you opt out
of the technique whenever you enter a
prompt that says beautiful summer
morning a person meditates on the top of
Mount Fuji watching the calm Sunset the
birds fly across a river and the air is
so pure in this blue nice sky
Hindu elderly man it is how shall I say
a philosophy it is we know what's good
for you overheard in Silicon Valley
safety safety safety open source on the
other hand stability AI is partnering up
with institutions around the world to
make localized models of stable
diffusion that seems to be much more
sensible to get sort of all of the world
to participate you go to places and you
let people there improve the model make
their own models so at the end it works
for those people too but oh man it did
not take long for people to not be happy
about this at all simply giving people
the tools and opportunity to be creative
that doesn't sit well with some people
Kotaku writes AI creating art is an
ethical and copyright nightmare
TechCrunch rights this startup is
setting a dolly too like AI free
consequences be damned you mean the
consequences that anyone has the ability
to make their own stuff oh yeah those be
damned rather we write a hit piece on
people but the same author at the same
publication wasn't quite satisfied so
about 10 days later another article deep
fakes for all uncensored Air Model
prompts ethics questions wow really two
articles two hit pieces gotta milk it
got a milk that was ethical questions
that are raised right but don't worry
the exact same author writes pieces such
as rephrase AI lands fresh investment to
grow its synthetic media platform in a
quite positive piece about a company
that makes synthetic media gee synthetic
media like image and video generation I
wonder what's the difference all right
this one is actually controlled behind
an API can be sold and can be controlled
by just having one or two people at the
correct places in a large company or in
the app store or in the play store or in
the appropriate journalistic channels
right here's another one win.ai launches
out of stealth with an AI assistant for
sales calls oh wait an AI assistant for
sales calls like you know like a bot
that makes sales calls for you know
sales people like the most annoying
calls you'll ever get and now it's an AI
doing it for them I guess at least you
can now swear at them without you having
to feel bad for them or something like
this again also completely positive
coverage I don't know the model that can
make Oprah Winfrey as an anime that's
the problem consequences be damned and
of course the AI ethics Community isn't
happy at all because what's ethical
about giving people access to tools and
and giving them the opportunity to make
great things that's terrible you can
always just pull one of like five
different standard insults from the
drawer and just accuse anyone that you
don't like of one of these when you've
got n Engineers cheerfully putting out
models they know to be racist you've got
a company with n racists you hear that
stability Tai that's all of you that's
that's all of you that's it that's what
it means and everyone taking part in it
we need organizations like hugging face
who is hosting stable diffusion for
public download to act with courage and
bring their might to the fire fighting
effort and addressing Ahmad mustak
directly if these Scholars are nobody to
you you are not qualified to work in
this space well that's the thing about
stuff being open and stuff being a free
market he doesn't need to be qualified
he can just do it it's fine but it's
very clear what's going on some people
enjoy the level of power that they have
in big organizations if there's just a
few big organizations a few big machine
learning conferences a few Publications
then you have a pretty solid grasp on
power you can make noise on Twitter and
you make sure that whatever happens
needs to go through one of those people
at least to get approval Distributing an
open model to anyone where any anyone
can improve anyone can do their thing
build their stuff in a decentralized
fashion means that power vanishes no one
has to ask specifically any one person
anymore whether they're allowed to do
something whether something is ethical
in their view or not I can't believe
stable diffusion is out there for public
use and that's considered as okay
yes yes that's okay now as you can see
the pressure on hogging face all of
these people is getting pretty intense
because how dare they just give
something to people well here is what a
member of their ethics team has to say
I'm concerned about these things being
over statements that function to give an
impression that the release is something
that ethics-minded AI people at least
that hogging face signed off on we do
not and did not sign off on anything we
advise within an open source community
that means we are working on licensing
documentation and release strategies
which any contributor can take or leave
we are a resource not approvers really
really I I recall I recall that was
quite different a few months ago the
evolution of centralized AI ethics don't
be evil we decide what is evil we decide
you are evil but what are they actually
saying right here well you know if you
have this model you could make any image
that you want any image you could make a
bad image like essentially they're
saying like okay wait
[Music]
essentially there's essentially what
they're saying is like this pen this pen
right here the fact that you can buy it
in the store is terrible because you
know what someone could do you know you
know someone could could like someone
could could could
someone could
someone could write a dirty word with it
but all that being said please let me
know what you think there is absolutely
issues around things like copyright here
maybe we need a new social contract like
you as an artist obviously put in a lot
of work into making these images is it
okay if then the machine simply grabs
them into the training data set
obviously it's okay for humans to be
inspired by other pictures but in the
world where machines can consume and
produce you know millions and billions
of images it tends to be a bit of a
different story so maybe Society needs
to evolve a little bit right there
nevertheless I feel the explosion of
creativity is great people are
infinitely creative with these things
and that is just such a good thing
overall and the fact that someone can
use it to make a nasty picture or the
fact that it doesn't work for all kinds
of pictures exactly the same to me it's
just such a non-starter and it seems to
be quite an dishonest argument that is
just aimed at further centralization of
power some people just don't like that
things are available to the public to
anyone without having to ask them first
if something is okay I'm not hating on
open AI or things like this who decide
to put their models behind an API but
don't at the same time talk about
democratizing AI like it's completely
cool you train a cool model you ask for
money for people to use it that's fine
but this is democratizing AI
democratizing means giving people access
to everything allowing people to take
things for themselves make it better and
give back to the community the explosion
of applications is absolutely great that
we've seen look at this this tool
creates a color palette from a text
nobody nobody at open AI came up with
this I'm fairly sure this is such a
unique application but such a great
thing you give a bunch of words you get
a color palette out how awesome is that
and that's what happens when you give
people the tools and access and freedom
and even better when the model runs on a
consumer GPU so anyone can use it hello
it's me from the editing room there's so
much stuff coming out I really thought
this should make this video but it
appeared literally today so I saw it
today this is dream textures which is an
endless texture generator in blender
directly in blender using stable
diffusion to create unique and seamless
textures
this is a playlist of stable diffusion
tutorials on YouTube
this is Char Lee which is an app that
will bring stable diffusion onto an M1
or M2 Mac in a single click and this is
stable diffusion implemented using
tensorflow and Keras by devam Gupta
props to divam for implementing this
here this is a serious effort not to be
joked about all right back to me in the
past but as I said let me know what you
think alright just a few things that
might be helpful too then the video is
over deep Garg on Twitter announces the
first ever Transformers seminar by
Stanford this is a seminar called
Transformers United and all the lectures
are on YouTube so if you want to know
something about Transformers from an
academic perspective place to go another
thing because it just starts like
yesterday is the shifts challenge 2022
which evaluates robustness and
uncertainty on real world data projects
include things like white matter
multiple sclerosis segmentation or
Marine cargo vessel power as estimations
so this is real world data and you have
to act under uncertainty and
distribution shifts and it's a challenge
so if you're into challenges this one's
starting right now all right so now I'm
gonna tell you how you enter the raffle
for the GPU this video is kindly
sponsored by Nvidia specifically they
want you to know about the GTC 2022 fall
Edition GTC is nvidia's developer
conference the one of the largest of its
kind it's free to attend and it's full
with amazing content of course the
keynote by Jensen Huang is the biggest
event and Jensen's gonna tell you all
about the future plans of Nvidia and
what's happening in the world of deep
learning GPU Computing and everything
around it now with Nvidia being the
market leader that it is I'd say that's
a pretty cool thing to attend now of
course the focus are going to be things
like more efficient deep learning but
also things like the metaverse VR and
collaboration such as this one Nvidia
and Siemens part partner up to enable
what they call the industrial Multiverse
so this connects nvidia's Omniverse
platform which is essentially a virtual
reality platform to simulate the real
world as closely as possible in order to
design to train and to make forecasts
this is being connected to the Siemens
accelerator which Siemens being the
hardware and sensor company that it is
is a platform for iot enabled hardware
and software so you can imagine that as
more and more of these companies pair up
their systems and team up we're gonna
get a richer and richer digital and real
hybrid world I think this comes pretty
close to the vision that Mark Zuckerberg
had for the metaverse and I'd say in
many ways closer than you know strapping
on a VR headset and running around in VR
chat so it's pretty cool to see the
industrial applications of this GTC is
going to be full with unique demos and
workshops that you can attend and of
course a lot of talks now next to the
keynote there's also a fireside chat
with a touring award winners they are
all going to be there young Lacon
Jeffrey and Joshua Benjo and for a full
hour they'll share their opinions about
the current state and future of AI
research okay here's how you get into
the raffle for the GPU go to
ykilcher.com GTC now it's important that
you sign up to GTC using my link this
will track you in their system but once
you've done that it's not enough you
actually need to attend GTC Well I
obviously suggest you attend the keynote
but you can attend any session but it
needs to be at least one session that
you attend of the GTC conference once
you've done that you'll be entered into
the raffle for the GPU I'll notify the
winner as soon as I know now there's one
caveat this only counts for people in
emea Europe the Middle East and Africa
if you happen to live there great enter
the raffle if you don't live there I'm
sorry I don't have power over this but
what I can do is I Can Raffle out a
bunch of merch such as shirts like these
so if you don't live in emea you can
enter the raffle there and and maybe get
a shirt or whatever you want essentially
so in any case the link is why
kilcher.com GTC and even if you do not
live in emea if you enter into the
raffle it'd be absolutely great if you
still attend the developer conference as
long as you sign up using the link
they'll still be able to track you and
that gives me brownie points with Nvidia
so again why culture.com GTC sign up to
the conference using that link attend at
least one session you'll be entered into
the raffle automatically alright that
was it thank you so much in video for
sponsoring this video I'll see you at
the GTC conference or in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
I was gonna write fun what did you think